hello and welcome back to another
edition of The Gadget Lab show I'm
Michael colori now I'm Nathan only got
his job we have some hot merchandise to
show off this week this is the Samsung
Galaxy Note oh yeah 10.1 tablet now last
time we had a galaxy note on the show it
was a phone a 5.3 inch smartphone with a
stylus and this is a 10.1 inch tablet
with a stylus also called the S Pen ya
know Samsung insists on calling at the S
Pen because it's not just a stylus and
actually it is just a stylus but um in
addition to the piece of hardware that
comes in the tablet it ships with a
bunch of apps that are specially tuned
to work with this with the S Pen y
they're called s-pen enabled or has been
optimized apps yep um so you guys have
been making some drawings on this right
yeah you know I've been test this out
for you know just about a week now wrote
a full review of it and there's a few
different specific you know s no capable
apps one was called s note and yeah I've
been drawing different things on it it's
actually kind of fun here I drew I was
kind of in progress spawn he doesn't
have an arm on the right side of his
body but hey it's work on projects good
that looks like you've got some serious
control with the pan and it's got some
pressure sensitivity yeah it's not bad
and you can actually get a decent amount
of detail especially if you you know
zoom in on different things but it's
nowhere close to the professional you
know like well wacom intuos or cintiq
tablets that are out there those are
really for professional animators and
artists and graphic designers and this
is really fun but it's really not at
that level just by having a much better
pin than what came on the phone right so
it's um it uses the same technology as
the cintiq yep same exact yeah same
exact technology from Wacom and there's
like no battery so that's great it's
it's really slick and I think it also if
you have other Wacom styluses you can
use those to you can use those on the
tablet as well that's what say
because it's the same technology so if
you have a bunch of those laying around
and you know you can just pick up this
device and we pick up one of the one of
the styluses and use it on the device
stylized ounces sorry i was gonna
confuse IOC's so other things that it
has that are optimized you can use it as
a navigation tool like when you're
clicking around from app to app you can
use the the pen to navigate the browser
that was the stock Android Ice Cream
Sandwich browser that ships on the
tablet is optimized for navigation it
works a lot like a hover State on a
mouse so like when you move a mouse over
something and the image changes or a
drop-down menu appears it does that but
the weird thing is it only works with
that browser so if you download a good
browser like Chrome it won't work it
won't work yeah which is a real bummer I
mean it shows that while Samsung is
doing some cool stuff and trying to be
innovative with the stylus they've still
got to open up you know an apk or
something to get other folks to to be
able to make apps that work with this as
well and unlimited we should mention
they are going to there will be a
development kit if there isn't one
already while you're watching this yeah
for the for the S Pen so if your
developer you can make an app that'll
work with the pen on this particular
tablet yeah now one other thing that's
kind of a bit of a letdown really
honestly with the note 10.1 is you have
a 1.4 gigahertz Samsung Exynos quad-core
processor in here so you have four cores
instead of two as you did in the galaxy
tab 2 10.1 which looks exactly the same
as the note 10.1 no confuse and yeah
yeah it is and you have two gigabytes of
ram instead of one as you did it last
tablet um but it doesn't perform any
faster I noticed that you kind of
noticed it too yeah it was kind of
little laggy so it's got it you know it
has a lot more capability but it doesn't
really show yeah even just navigating
through menus swiping around you know
just using a tablet in everyday use it
doesn't feel noticeably faster
especially when compared to other great
tablets like the Nexus 7 which is 200
bucks right we should mention this is
500 yeah for the 16 gigabyte version and
five hundred fifty dollars for the
32 gig version and for 500 bucks you
know you can get an iPad you can get I
think the the transformer is transformer
pad infinity it was 500 an around the
same price as so comparatively priced
tablets you can get a lot more
performance but you don't get the fancy
pen yep and as cool as the pen isn't as
much fun it is as it is to take some
notes they even have a text book app
here you can you know highlight
different sections it doesn't feel like
a killer feature that really makes you
want to pick this up versus those other
really top line competing tablet it does
have some other things which we've I
think in our assessment have considered
kind of minor like it has an IR blaster
yep so you can use it as a remote
control on your entertainment system
your TV or whatever micro SD card slot
microsd card slot there's the ability to
throw the image to a television viewing
a little Wi-Fi hdmi dongle yeah yeah it
was kinda nice going on with you because
mirroring so if you want to give a
presentation it has sharing features
built-in so if you're in a room with a
bunch of people who have either Galaxy
Note tablets or galaxy s3 smart phones
you can share presentations you can
share photos with all those people but
it requires everybody you're sharing
with to have the same device as you yeah
and the sharing is kind of clunky kind
of sucks all the spontaneity out of it
which is really what sharing is about
right yep sobh over so that stuff aside
and the pen aside what do you think for
500 bucks for 500 bucks there's there's
better tablets out there for your money
it's that simple um you know this is
essentially the same exact tablet as the
galaxy tab 2 10.1 which was behind the
times Bolton speed and even the display
quality of a 1280 by 800 display here
which isn't even close to what you're
getting on the iPad or the you know
transformer infinity so as you know as
cool as the note is and the the S Pen is
it's just not enough in my in my opinion
to make this the best android tablet out
there the killer android tablet
and one thing I will say to the tablets
credit is when the galaxy note came out
we thought it was kind of silly because
it's kind of you know you writing on it
is is interesting but it's not quite
killer yeah drawing and writing on this
thing is a lot better so if you like
that about the Galaxy Note but you
thought the screen was too small you'll
probably really dig this and and Samsung
has sold millions of no phones yeah and
I didn't think they would yo you know
maybe they'll sell millions of these
yeah they will but never know we shall
see yep um anyway that's just about all
the time we have for this week and you
can read Nate's full review of the
galaxy note 10.1 tablet from samsung on
wired com / reviews yep and we'll be
back next week with more cool stuff to
show you oh yeah oh yes see you then
until then bite